das schmeckt so wie wenn du im kino ein
abschluss mit käse tipp ist und die
schon da ein bisschen länger darum
stehen so schmeckt das klingt ja super
und dann auch noch hier unten drittel
braucht sorry aber nicht raus tut mir
leid
hey du hast gedacht und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja den
schaffen hat was ist das volk du hast
vertrag komplett ich habe sowieso
gemacht da macht man von sich sagen hey
du hast gedacht und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video erhalte ich hoffe
natürlich euch jedes jetzt ist mir das
gar nicht eingefallen was wolltet ihr
seid gut war ganz groß was zu lustig wie
der band frankie bringen leute gestern
der bergwelt einer wenn er dort gesehen
habe das war ja das allerheiligste ich
mache hier kostet die karte maschine
auszumachen nebengeräusche
ich bitte sie zitierte was geht
heute haben wir folgendes vor und zwar
zu machen macht doch hier das video ich
wollte nicht tun und zwar nach wie vor
drei monaten
zwei videos gebracht das ist auf jeden
fall kam da videos neue fast food trends
von mcdonald's oder so und ich war es
hier einmal darauf das wieder was neues
kommt zu dieser zeit haben wir richtig
was rausgehauen
aber da kam nichts dann ist mir die idee
gekommen nochmal bei burger king
und die haben echt ein paar neue sachen
irgendwie sowas mit avocado und so und
da habe ich gedacht das ist auf jeden
fall ein video wert deswegen haben wir
am mittag ich schnappe mir jetzt den
juli da hinter der kamera stehen und
seine beine zusammenhält und in farbe zu
bekennen und bestellen mal und zwar
haben hier nach chili cheese nagel also
das sind nicht diese normalen chili
cheese nuggets sondern nacho so hey was
ist also kann ich mir gar nicht
vorstellen mag amberger guacamole banken
kämen deswegen wie mexikanische woche
oder weiß ich auch nicht ob sam brown
und so weiter
ja es ist dazu jetzt sollen sie hat juri
das ist wieder mal wollte ja es kann ich
aber nicht wenn du ja du wirst mir
gleich her und dann haben wir noch lange
bürger dass leute juli hat schon gesagt
wir suchen uns echt immer die dümmsten
zeiten aus ihrem 14 uhr da ist dieser
berg in würde nur kurz hin wollen
normalerweise fährt und von mir aus
zuhause maximal fünf minuten
jetzt stehen wir schon wieder hier im
stau seit zehn minuten oder so weil da
vorne eine baustelle ist also das sind
immer so sachen die kann man natürlich
nicht mit einplanen
ich melde mich dann wir sehen uns gleich
warum regst du dich hier offen sind
eingezogen
ich bin auf diese treffen sind was die
kämpfe angekommen
ich hatte gerne einmal die nato chili
cheese nur geht's dann diesen brauch ja
genau und dann den gorka mole bacon
bürger einzeln leone und
gorka mond schicken das wäre hat er
jetzt chili cheese ja ich will jetzt
nicht so viele bürger bestellen weil ich
bin eigentlich nicht so der verein
das kostet fast 8 10 euro für zwei
burger diese chili cheese dinger unten
muffin oder so bin ich bei premium
burger king oder wie
[Musik]
sechseinhalb stunden später danke danke
wer im ganzen betrieb aufgehalten
ehrlich ich glaube diese frage ich
glaube diese kvaca modischen bestehen
nicht so viele leute wir sind jetzt
endlich mal raus aus diesem drive das
wird ewig gedauert wie er habe ich jetzt
die quittung dabei ich habe spaß 18 euro
bezahlt das heißt einen goya oder der
hat mich abgezogen
ich hab gezogen das kind kann auch nicht
sein also schreibt dass man die
kommentare das kann nicht sein
ein bürger müsste sechs euro kosten das
macht es ja gar keinen sinn oder meinst
ich hätte jetzt nur mit 12 oder sogar 18
also leute wir sind jetzt zu hause
angekommen
ich muss aber sagen ich wundere mich
immer noch weil also 18 euro ist für
mich für so was jetzt brutal viel und er
hat mir auch keine quittung gegeben und
hier ist auch keine quittung drin also
ich bin der festivals
da ist was im busch einspielung die
trovato weißt du was ich das erst mal
mache ich gucke jetzt bei dieser burger
bestellen wie teuer das ist nicht mit
mir
mit mir kann man alles in die kommentare
folter sorgen wie ein clown geschichtet
nicht es passt guacamole baking sieben
euro 5
was ist also ist das ist ja wie als wenn
ich jetzt zu einem guten burger laden
gehe
naja gut akzeptiert dann halt auch nicht
übers ohr gehauen
also wir haben hier erstmal habe ich
noch nie probiert kann man hier sieht ja
aus wie eine muschel oder so was ist das
zimt oder und zimt und sind braune oder
so ja der ist neu auf jeden fall warten
ehe mache ich am schluss machen oder was
wird sozusagen als nachtisch uns nach
tüv genommen
dann haben wir hier keine chili cheese
lang ist sondern nacho chili cheese
nuggets also wahrscheinlich ist dann
noch sind da noch matthus drin oder so
ich will ich als erstes studieren und
dann haben wir hier als sieger aus
diesem tag sogar irgendwie das sind ja
riesige berge und das ding sich hast du
diese fetten bürger so von mcdonald's
oder burger king
irgendwie finde ich die solche ketten
dinger viel zu viel
danach fühlten uns hier ein ekelhafter
richtig also ich habe den letzten big
bag nicht gegessen habe das schon drei
jahre ja naja gut nur ich gebe dem
ganzen natürlich eine chance weil der
skk bohle drauf guacamole auf dem burger
habe ich auch noch nie gehört fangen wir
hier mit am tisch ist jetzt kennt ihr ja
wahrscheinlich früher sehr viele
gegessen
aber irgendwann war es den zug wieder
dann habe ich die ich mich mag ihn nicht
mal sogar weiße das schmeckt so wie wenn
du im kino ein abschluss mit käse tipp
ist und ich schon ein bisschen länger
darum stehen so schmeckt das klingt ja
super sich das auch nicht so lecker aus
oder lag es mit süß saurer soße drin
dass herr meine idee ist auch jetzt so
in den nuggets dieser kerl war oder was
so unnötig oder da muss man nicht immer
in diese server seien aber ist dieses
jahr also wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich
warm
naja vielleicht irgendwie überhaupt
nicht also muss ich als punkte verteilen
wirst du nur drei von zehn
aber muss ich also glück und jetzt haben
wir hier diese diese fetten burger oder
lieblich zusammengestellt und wurst
heißt ach ja und hier ist jetzt einfach
die kamera drauf geklappt ich muss sagen
sieht auch gar nicht so schlecht aus
aber ich probiere das jetzt mal und dann
sag ich ob es mir schmeckt oder halt
hier gehen man falls auch nicht junge
ist das ein riesenbagger wer ist denn so
was
also ich muss sagen ich probiere ich mal
bei marie zb sogar kamele weil die ist
immer sogar kam ohne trost mit tomaten
und erschreckt wirklich frisch echt gut
aber das schmeckt wie chlor oder so also
ganz komisch ich finde dass sie gar
nicht schlecht aus aber diese guacamole
wieder drauf ist also ich habe noch
nicht schlechtere guacamole gegessen das
ticken hier seht ihr eigentlich ganz gut
aus
vielleicht ist das ja bei dem brief
dingen besser ok deutschem arbeiter
als nächstes haben wir dann dieses wrack
am boden
bacon king hieß er glaube ich also wie
das sonst das gerät für sieben euro
sie sprechen natürlich dass der speed da
ist kein weg gut ich habe doch gesagt
wie ich geholt ich habe ihm gesagt dass
er vergessen
ich habe dir doch gesagt du hast noch an
vergessen
[Musik]
und dann der burghalle bacon bürger
einzeln hast du ja ich dachte man schon
rat als nächstes haben wir hier den ball
kam ohne beute ich weiß es bei dem
schicken dann ging es irgendwie noch so
halbwegs aber findest du findest du das
sind lecker aus ich finde er sieht
irgendwie leckere aus angst als der
andere so recht war ich weiß nicht ich
kann euch wirklich nur raten für sieben
euro geht geht mal kommt gerne nach köln
sagen wir bescheid ich hole euch ab und
dann gehen wir mal zu einem richtig
vernünftigen guttenberger laden wo man
das da ist hier den besten burger eures
lebens er ist doch so hallo bitte sieben
euro ist das nicht wert das war jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen zuvor
eingenommen guck mal hier unten ist
sogar so so fleischreste denkst du dir
manchmal auch so das auge isst mit
in jedem normalen bürger laden auch wenn
die schlechter schmecken bekommst du ein
schöner gemacht haben war ja also ich
würde ja sie kann sich an alle die jetzt
sagen alex frei man nicht so rum ich
habe bis jetzt bei noch keinem neue fast
food trends video zum gehalt aber gebt
euch das mag das ist noch nicht das also
und dann auch noch hier unten drin
braucht sorry aber nicht aus tut mir
leid wollen wir haben ja zum glück noch
den brownie der auch aussieht wie eine
muschel die eben wie gerade kuriert ist
aber riechen tut gut wieder auf fleisch
festkleider sind keine fläche
das beste kommt kann man ja so gut immer
zum schluss und war kann man hier ja gut
das sieht jetzt geil aus
wird so ein bisschen füllung hier daran
sieht man dass das sieht noch mehr nach
akkurat aus echt ok ich ja nach
weihnachten also ein bisschen was holt
er auf jeden fall jetzt wieder raus
nicht zu viel nur man muss ja auch nur
man muss ja auch sagen das ist ein ding
das wird einfach so geliefert und die
müssen es nur aufwärmen bei dem bürger
muss man noch ein bisschen selber was
machen zusammen stapeln und das war
wirklich heute von den bürgern her die
dann neu sind mit cracker mode darauf
kann ich euch nicht empfehlen also mein
geschmack
das gar nicht eklig zusammengepasst
total lieblos ich meine klar ich habe
jetzt auch nicht die höchsten
anforderungen aber ich habe selten so
schlecht erlebt und ich habe schon viele
videos in diesem themenbereich gedreht
sagen wir mal so ich hoffe natürlich ist
hat euch trotzdem gefallen vielleicht
ist es jetzt das erste video wo ich dann
in den kommentaren normalerweise steht
immer in den kommentaren danke alex die
habe ich jetzt hunger vielleicht steht
heute mehr drin
danke alex jetzt habe ich keinen hunger
mehr kann er sein
naja gut wir sehen uns dann
wahrscheinlich morgen um 19 uhr wieder
gibt es ein neues video
juli nicht drin jetzt gleich noch ein
weiteres video wird es jetzt gleich
einen schuh der es unzerstörbare ein
sneaker ja da kannst du über nägel gehen
und so überteuert machen wir das ja und
wir heute marisa und mache ich es auch
so wird gehalten ja also das war's dann
nach oben abonniert den kanal lockert
die wir sehen uns half st